as we go further in our statistical
careers it's going to be valuable to
assume that certain distributions are
normal distributions or sometimes to
assume that they are binomial
distributions because if we can do that
we can make all sorts of interesting
inferences about them
when we make that assumption but one of
the key things about normal
distributions or binomial distributions
is we assume that they're the sum or
they can be viewed as the sum of a bunch
of independent trials
so we have to assume that trials
trials
are
independent
now that is reasonable in a lot of
situations but sometimes let's say
you're conducting a survey of people
exiting a mall and in that case let's
say you're saying whether they have done
their taxes already if they're exiting
the mall it's hard to do these samples
with replacement they're leaving them
all you can't say hey wait i just asked
you a question now you've answered it
now go back into the mall because i want
each trial to be truly independent but
we all know it feels intuitive that hey
if there are 10 000 people in the mall
and i'm going to sample 10 of them does
it really matter that it's truly
independent doesn't it matter that we're
just kind of close to being independent
and because of that idea and because we
do want to make inferences based on
things being close to a binomial
distribution or a normal distribution we
have something called the 10
percent rule
and the 10 percent rule says that if our
sample
if our sample
is less than or equal to 10 percent
of the population
then it is okay
to assume approximate independence
approximate
in the
pendants
and there are some fairly sophisticated
ways of coming up with this ten percent
threshold people could have picked nine
percent they could have picked ten point
one percent but ten percent is a nice
round number and if we look at some
tangible examples it seems to do a
pretty good job
so for example right over here
let's let x be the number of boys from
three trials of selecting from a
classroom of n students where 50 of the
class is a boy and 50
of the class is a girl and so what we
have over here is we have a bunch of
different ends what if we have 20
students in the class what if we have 30
what if we have 100 what if we have 10
000 and so we could find the probability
that we select three boys with
replacement in each of these scenarios
and we could also find the probability
that we select three boys without
replacement and then we could think
about what proportion is our sample size
of the entire population and then we
could say hey does the 10 percent rule
actually make sense
so this first column where we are
picking three boys with replacement in
this case because we are replacing each
of these trials are independent
are truly
independent and in our trials are
independent then x would be truly a
binomial variable here
we aren't independent because we are not
replacing so not
in
dependent and so officially in this
column right over here when we're not
replacing x would not be considered a
binomial random variable but let's see
if there's a threshold where if our
sample size is a small enough percentage
of our entire population where we would
feel not so bad about assuming x is
close to being binomial
so in all of the cases where you have
independent trials and 50 percent of the
population is boys 50 is girls well
you're
going to amount to one-half times
one-half times one-half so in all of
those situations you have a 12.5 percent
chance that x is going to be equal to
three and in this case x would be a
binomial variable
but look over here when we when three is
a fairly large percentage of our
population in this case it is fifteen
percent the percent chance of getting
three boys without replacement
is ten point five percent which is
reasonably different from twelve and a
half percent it is two percent different
but two percent relative to twelve and a
half percent so that's some place in
between ten and twenty percent
difference in terms of the probability
so this is a reasonably big difference
but as we increase the population size
without increasing the sample size we
see that these numbers get closer and
closer to each other all the way so that
if you have 10 000 people in your
population and you're only doing three
trials that the numbers get very very
close this is actually 12.49 something
percent but if you round to the nearest
tenth of a percent you see that they are
close so i think most people would say
all right if your sample is three ten
thousandths of the population that you'd
feel pretty good treating this column
without replacement as being pretty
close to being a binomial variable
and most people would say all right this
first scenario where your sample size is
15 of your population you wouldn't feel
so good treating this without
replacement column as a binomial random
variable
but where do you draw the line
and as we alluded to earlier in the
video the line is typically drawn at 10
percent that if your sample size is less
than or equal to 10 of your population
it's not unreasonable to treat your
random variable even though it's not
officially binomial to say okay maybe it
is maybe i can functionally treat it but
as binomial and then from there i can
make all of the powerful inferences that
we tend to do in statistics with that
said the lower the percentage the sample
is of the population the better now to
be clear that's not saying that small
sample sizes are better than large
sample sizes in statistics large sample
sizes tend to be a lot better than small
sample sizes but if you want to make
this independence assumption so to speak
even when it's not exactly true you want
your sample to be a small percentage of
the population so the ideal let's say
you're doing a survey at the mall you
might want to survey 100 people but you
would hope that there's at least a
thousand people in the mall in order for
you to feel like your trials are
reasonably independent if there's 10 000
people in the mall or somehow 50 000
people in the mall which would be a very
large mall
well that that's even better